all right.
NOTE CONF
The ELEN is driving crazy.
OK, three.
NOTE CONF
What do you wanna talk about?
You can do whatever you want.
NOTE CONF
Four.
Uh, I mean, I'm not I'm only half joking.
NOTE CONF
I've got a lecture to give, obviously, but I, um
clearly, nobody's that interested in the lectures.
NOTE CONF
So we might as well talk about what you're interest
we wanna talk about.
NOTE CONF
Is there anything that you've struggled with?
That you want to know more about?
NOTE CONF
Any thoughts you've got so far you can spend some
time on Just, you know, something that you I've been
NOTE CONF
interested in or struggling with?
Oh, I have.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
Uh, can we connect the iPad, um, to the med
NOTE CONF
to, um, avoid the Yeah, let's try.
You can try and teach me how to do that,
NOTE CONF
because when I look for the, um, echo payback.
But there's some that Ah.
NOTE CONF
OK, well, how on earth do I do that?
Do you know how?
NOTE CONF
Um I think the, um, control.
Maybe there's a screen mirror so I can screen mirror.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, to the, um, Mac and Mac.
Yeah, but if I do that, does it not take
NOTE CONF
it?
Let's have a look.
NOTE CONF
Let's have a Look, Yeah, I gotta be on the
same network.
NOTE CONF
I gotta be logged in with the same bloody iCloud
thingy, which I think I got sorted.
NOTE CONF
We're on one net.
We're on one net, and then I go, It's like
NOTE CONF
an aeroplane thing, right?
Yeah, I.
NOTE CONF
I mean, I know it's what we're trying to get
away from, but I'll do this so people can point
NOTE CONF
me in the right direction.
I'm over here, right?
NOTE CONF
Uh, maybe.
Right, lady.
NOTE CONF
Looks like my pin stopped working, which is a massive
hassle.
NOTE CONF
So it's freaking Do that, Uh, you mean on this
one?
NOTE CONF
This one?
The payroll.
NOTE CONF
And that's that computer.
But now it's taken over my screen.
NOTE CONF
So is there a way to shrink that window?
Uh, OK, so the idea is that I just leave
NOTE CONF
this connected and I mirror between the two.
Alright.
NOTE CONF
The downside then is I can't look at the code
at the same time as I'm writing, which is something
NOTE CONF
I do quite a lot of.
But then OK, uh, I'm trying to looking for, like,
NOTE CONF
three mirror.
You mean that you have, uh, yeah, exactly.
NOTE CONF
It takes over the whole screen, which seems weird, right?
because the apple should design, like even the T or
NOTE CONF
something like that school.
Yeah, I know.
NOTE CONF
I can do it the other way where I I
grow this screen over to this screen, But then can
NOTE CONF
I write on the screen?
So I've gotta, like do that.
NOTE CONF
And now I'm over here, which you can't see, But
that's not gonna help, because it's not gonna be projected.
NOTE CONF
OK, so that's no good.
Alright, well, we'll try that out today.
NOTE CONF
It'll stop me from getting mixed up as to which
one I'm on as well.
NOTE CONF
Have you found you yet?
Yes.
NOTE CONF
You have CO.
Alright.
NOTE CONF
There you go.
That was useful, maybe.
NOTE CONF
OK.
Any other thoughts?
NOTE CONF
Suggestions?
Hm?
NOTE CONF
We are talking about Scala this week.
Are you excited to talk about Scala?
NOTE CONF
Yeah, hell yeah.
And God, Damien's here.
NOTE CONF
He brought the enthusiasm Jala first.
No, no, we'll stick to the plan.
NOTE CONF
Well, no, I can.
Oh, that's not good.
NOTE CONF
Break the whole thing off.
OK?
NOTE CONF
Computer's left.
Still not seeing my computer, nothing's needed.
NOTE CONF
Oh, because it's But, uh oh, He still sounds a
bit snotty over there.
NOTE CONF
Probably it will take 20 months.
I already had a I've already had a coffee, and
NOTE CONF
now I'm on the coke already, and it's only 9.
30.
NOTE CONF
0, my Lord.
Yes.
NOTE CONF
No comments are appearing, but a few more people have
turned up online.
NOTE CONF
Uh, okey dokey.
So let's just do admin stuff we got Simon got
NOTE CONF
submitted, right?
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
And we gotta work on getting that marked in the
next week and a half.
NOTE CONF
How do you feel about this?
I mean, you can just go, Uh uh uh comes
NOTE CONF
up.
It's pretty damn easy, right?
NOTE CONF
Is it too easy?
You could say the next one's already set.
NOTE CONF
I'm not gonna change the next one.
Yeah, it was way too easy, but, uh, we next
NOTE CONF
one is end to end, and hopefully, you know, I
mean, this is the This is the formative slash summative
NOTE CONF
assessment thing where some assessments are set, mostly to find
out what you know.
NOTE CONF
Some assessments are set mostly to force you to learn
something cos otherwise students weren't engaged, and I saw that
NOTE CONF
very clearly I was I was second guessing my decision
until I went to the workshop last week.
NOTE CONF
And, uh, only two people in the workshop even had
any locks.
NOTE CONF
Code that they copy pasted into a VS code and
tried to run.
NOTE CONF
And then the third person who was quick at doing
that tried to press the play button on visual studio
NOTE CONF
code.
And I'm like, Oh my God, we all OK?
NOTE CONF
So yes, it was.
It was a necessary learning experience to force everyone to
NOTE CONF
actually get a locks interpreter running, which you now have.
Well, we'll see how many when we do the grading,
NOTE CONF
so forcing function done.
Locks Interpreter created free marks for anyone who's paying attention.
NOTE CONF
Hooray!
Now, second assessment is gonna be like end to end,
NOTE CONF
making a change in the Interpreter that has to go
through execution and all that jazz.
NOTE CONF
And yeah, it'll be related to the Reed and the
Rand, and there might be a bit more as well,
NOTE CONF
but so that we can create more interesting locks programmes.
OK, we may add a few other primitives that are
NOTE CONF
fun.
We may add another control flow that doesn't exist.
NOTE CONF
We may add a different way to do certain features
in the language.
NOTE CONF
Um, but we get a long way already right.
We haven't got to control flow.
NOTE CONF
Uh, once we get into control flow.
There are variables.
NOTE CONF
This week we got control flow first time after the
break.
NOTE CONF
Functions are a really interesting topic that we get to
give a bit of time to.
NOTE CONF
Given the timing, you can probably see that we might
struggle to get functions into the assignment functions themselves.
NOTE CONF
But it's very likely given how the kind of person
I am that I'm gonna give you something functional like
NOTE CONF
that maybe only requires knowledge from the previous weeks, but
pushes you to think about the same things that the
NOTE CONF
functional week talks about.
That's my way of threading the needle.
NOTE CONF
Same thing we did earlier with the the advanced programming
task where, you know, you didn't need to know the
NOTE CONF
scanning stuff, but it was helpful to think about the
scanning.
NOTE CONF
So that's coming up.
And we're all doing past exams right now.
NOTE CONF
And you're also gonna tell me that's super easy.
Too Super easy.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, same story, you know, forcing function.
But the distinction exam will not be super easy.
NOTE CONF
Timing wise.
I mean, a lot of questions on this distinction exam.
NOTE CONF
Uh, we are at least gonna have to run one
session in week nine.
NOTE CONF
The first week back.
So some people who have let me know they're not
NOTE CONF
available in the holidays get first dibs to allocate into
that session.
NOTE CONF
Um, but I can't think of a good reason not
to put a few sessions in that week anyway.
NOTE CONF
So when they open up, it's likely you're gonna see
a few in the second half of next week and
NOTE CONF
then a few in the first half of week nine
for you to choose your times from.
NOTE CONF
So for those who are away on the holidays, you
want to get in quick to the first of the
NOTE CONF
week.
Nines Everyone else.
NOTE CONF
It's better to do it in the first week of
the holidays because it allows you to study that concept.
NOTE CONF
Get that concept sorted.
You've done the past exam.
NOTE CONF
It's forefront in your mind.
It you'll do better in the distinction exam the sooner
NOTE CONF
you do it to your study of the material, Uh,
but for those who can't, uh, the other option will
NOTE CONF
be available.
And, as I said, there's an opt in.
NOTE CONF
Uh, don't choose an option unless you plan to make
a genuine attempt at the exam and the don't expect
NOTE CONF
the second past exam to be quite as easy as
the first one when we get the exam two, which
NOTE CONF
is again the the Exam two will only test the
second half of the course.
NOTE CONF
Right.
So you obviously can't unload the first half of the
NOTE CONF
course from your brain and just start studying the second
half because they're all so tightly related.
NOTE CONF
But you're not gonna find questions in the second half
that are precisely about just those topics.
NOTE CONF
OK, any other questions on those before I move on?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
NOTE CONF
Alright, let's do this second half of statements and state.
And then Scala.
NOTE CONF
OK, so we made it down to all the parsing
and the basics of evaluation and thinking about some of
NOTE CONF
the ins and outs of how we might pass something
more complex.
NOTE CONF
Well, not more complex than an expression, but in a
different form than an expression.
NOTE CONF
And the fact that assignment might be an expression or
might be a, uh, S statement came up.
NOTE CONF
Did that come up last week, or is that coming
up this week?
NOTE CONF
Coming up this week, Uh, I get mixed up in
my head because I do I do it all?
NOTE CONF
I did this chapter all in one hit.
Uh, but I know for sure we haven't done environments
NOTE CONF
yet, so that's that's our key.
Let's get some locks code up and running so that
NOTE CONF
we can start to think about what the heck might
even have to go on with interpreters.
NOTE CONF
I want to be.
Look at all this stuff I got on my screen.
NOTE CONF
I wanna be in Week eight.
That's the end of week eight.
NOTE CONF
But that's fine.
We did weeks ago.
NOTE CONF
They went to Java weeks.
And so if it peaked, end of week eight.
NOTE CONF
We've got variables, so just give me a sec.
Mhm.
NOTE CONF
Hm?
Oh, OK.
NOTE CONF
So this is me with my week eight co again.
I'm showing you my dev layout because a lot of
NOTE CONF
students aren't getting a good Dev layout yet, and it's
always a good reminder.
NOTE CONF
And in fact, once code bases get complicated, the way
you organise your code base is maybe 30% of the
NOTE CONF
challenge.
Um, because if you put that cognitive overload on yourself
NOTE CONF
just understanding what the heck's going on my code base
before I can get going, you're just making life harder.
NOTE CONF
So for me, I've got the full copy and a
reminder.
NOTE CONF
You know, it's in its own package.
So I just update the packages, and then off we
NOTE CONF
go.
And this one here has got everything from week eight.
NOTE CONF
Hopefully, if I did it, if I didn't stop halfway
through, loaded up.
NOTE CONF
And I've got versions of various locks.
Programmes?
NOTE CONF
Um, I started labelling them with an eight in front
if it required the week eight material.
NOTE CONF
So, uh, these are some ones I think I've given
you in the, uh, workshop.
NOTE CONF
So we will leave those alone, and maybe we'll write
our own.
NOTE CONF
So let's make a new locks programme here in we
gate and oops, we will call it eight.
NOTE CONF
Make sure dot Lux.
So the types of things we're thinking about are And
NOTE CONF
get me.
Tell me if I get my syntax wrong because, uh,
NOTE CONF
I've been doing multiple languages again.
As always.
NOTE CONF
Um, this week we've done scala locks, java, python and
seed.
NOTE CONF
What in the last two days, Um, so I think
it's vase in lock.
NOTE CONF
VX equals three.
So we had that already.
NOTE CONF
Um, but we weren't able to use any variables.
because we weren't doing anything with them.
NOTE CONF
So hopefully, uh, I gotta go into Java.
Java, so to run my interpreter, I say I save
NOTE CONF
that as a file and I say J, I've already
compiled it.
NOTE CONF
I think so.
It's Java minus CP dot slash weeks eight Lux And
NOTE CONF
then I give you the file name, which is weeks
eight eight.
NOTE CONF
Lecture the locks and it runs it in front of
the three.
NOTE CONF
So So nothing fancy now, but we've got to think
to ourselves how and what do they have to do
NOTE CONF
to make sense out of that?
The interpreter, which was just running line by line, had
NOTE CONF
to know somehow keep track of the fact that X
was three at this point.
NOTE CONF
Well, you can probably think of a fairly easy way
to do that.
NOTE CONF
Maybe I'm just gonna put a variable in my interpreter
code X and make it equal to three.
NOTE CONF
Um, but making variables in Java happens at compile time,
so I can't do that at run time.
NOTE CONF
An alternative, though, and the one they suggest in the
book is to use yourself a hash map or a
NOTE CONF
dictionary or whatever Hash map dictionary or whatever being are
you gonna do your business?
NOTE CONF
See, now I squished it up.
But maybe if I do this, does that help?
NOTE CONF
Oh, yeah, OK, hash map, dictionary or whatever being any
old structure.
NOTE CONF
So we know arrays look like this, right, and we
index them with numbers.
NOTE CONF
Hash map is exactly the same thing, or a dictionary
or whatever, except I get to control the index.
NOTE CONF
So instead of the index definitely being a number, I've
got a key and a value.
NOTE CONF
And whenever I put something in the hash map, I
have to tell it which key it's going with and
NOTE CONF
what value you guys are.
So just give me one sec.
NOTE CONF
Come on, come on.
So if we chose the variable as the key and
NOTE CONF
the value and the value, then our interpreter could keep
track Nice.
NOTE CONF
That's pretty simple, but that's what it is.
That's how we do unless here is called.
NOTE CONF
And well, there's many, many names I gave hash map
dictionary associated array.
NOTE CONF
But when we're in an interpreter, we'll call it the
environment, and the reason we call it the environment is
NOTE CONF
that at any particular line of code, it's showing us
the execution environment.
NOTE CONF
This is slow.
What I mean by that is above this line of
NOTE CONF
code.
The execution environment should be empty because there's no variables.
NOTE CONF
There's no functions.
There's no nothing in between these two lines.
NOTE CONF
The environment should be that X equals three because we've
introduced a new variable.
NOTE CONF
Um and it's been set to three and after this
line, that environment should be the same.
NOTE CONF
But if I make my programme longer, OK, then here
it's an empty environment here it's an environment only with
NOTE CONF
an X equals three.
Same again.
NOTE CONF
Here here it's now an environment where X equals three
and why?
NOTE CONF
And there's another Y equals five and same thing down
here so we can keep track of that simply by
NOTE CONF
using this same environment and just updating it as we
go.
NOTE CONF
And that's really what storing state is in a interpreter.
So I would add of Y equals five here.
NOTE CONF
But at the first step on the first line of
the programme, the environment looks like this.
NOTE CONF
On the second line of the programme, the environment looks
like this.
NOTE CONF
On the fifth line of the environment of the programme,
the environment looks like this, and this all seems super
NOTE CONF
obvious at this point.
But I'm wanting you to see that that environment not
NOTE CONF
only will help you find out the value of any
of your variables, it will also help you find out
NOTE CONF
which variables exist so that you can give errors if
someone tries to use a variable before it exists.
NOTE CONF
Now I think the book talks about the fact that
we might prefer using a variable before it exists to
NOTE CONF
be a static error, the kind of error that comes
up before we try and run the programme.
NOTE CONF
Oh, and just to sidetrack here, static versus dynamic errors
is a little trickier to talk about with locks than
NOTE CONF
it is with other programmes, so I'm gonna be clear
about it again.
NOTE CONF
I think I've already been clear once or twice but
never hurts in Java.
NOTE CONF
A bunch of things happen when we compile and another
bunch of things happen when we run.
NOTE CONF
So the compile things are all done by Java.
The run things are all done by Java.
NOTE CONF
JX sometimes gives you errors.
Those are the static errors or compile time errors that
NOTE CONF
J AC's able to work out you can never catch
every error at compile time, so Java also will sometimes
NOTE CONF
give you runtime errors.
We should hopefully prefer to get our errors earlier rather
NOTE CONF
than later.
We should prefer to get our errors before we run
NOTE CONF
the programme rather than while we're running the programme.
So we like static errors.
NOTE CONF
We like to move errors from run time to compile
time or from dynamic time to static time.
NOTE CONF
Those all mean the same thing.
So that's what I'm talking about here is that even
NOTE CONF
in locks there's still a static time and a run
time or a dynamic time.
NOTE CONF
The static time is everything that happens before the interpreter
fires up the interpreter class and then run.
NOTE CONF
Time is everything that happens while the interpreter is actually
executing the programme.
NOTE CONF
So we can still talk about moving our areas from
compile time to run time even though we don't have
NOTE CONF
separate compile programmes and run programmes.
But the user is not gonna see a big difference.
NOTE CONF
They're just gonna see I ran and it gave me
an error, but we as internal programme compile writer, can
NOTE CONF
try and put them in the compile time cos that
gives us the option.
NOTE CONF
One of the reasons that option is important is even
in an interpreter.
NOTE CONF
This compile time is fixed and short and run Time
is potentially infinite and always longer.
NOTE CONF
So, as a compiler writer, as an interpreter writer, I
have the option just like you did with your first
NOTE CONF
assessment of saying Run this interpreter.
But don't run every phase.
NOTE CONF
Just run the scan phase or just run the PAS
phase.
NOTE CONF
Don't run the interpreter phase that allows the programmer to
do all of the analysis that can be done statically
NOTE CONF
and not have to run it for OK, in case
running it might touch other services or running.
NOTE CONF
It might take five hours to get to the air
estate, so on and so forth.
NOTE CONF
Alright, so this is one where we would like to
do it at compile time sometime earlier in the compiler
NOTE CONF
than the interpreter.
But, uh, this is where Locke shows us something interesting.
NOTE CONF
OK, let's see.
What does this programme look like as an A ST?
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna draw it and then switch over to
the drawing so it looks like a we had a
NOTE CONF
declaration note.
Actually, maybe I'll switch over.
NOTE CONF
So it's so someone tell me if I'm wrong.
Um, but I think we get from from this one.
NOTE CONF
Once we pass this into a parse tree, we're gonna
get a list of statements.
NOTE CONF
Yep, we do.
I know there'll be four of them.
NOTE CONF
I can see them straight away.
Yeah, And the first one, the first statement's gonna be
NOTE CONF
a decal variable declaration.
And that verbal declaration is gonna have a X token.
NOTE CONF
And the three value and the second statement is gonna
be a print statement, which is going to have a
NOTE CONF
single expression, which is X.
And the third statement is gonna be a decal again
NOTE CONF
with a Y token and the five and the next
one is a print statement with a This is a
NOTE CONF
binary up, and the binary operation is the plus with
the X.
NOTE CONF
I don't know why.
I think that's what my abstract syntax tree looks like.
NOTE CONF
So that's another useful place to note that now that
we've got this setup abstract syntax, trees aren't just single
NOTE CONF
things anymore.
Well, it kind of is, cos there's kind of a
NOTE CONF
list up here, so the root of it is really
just one list made of multiple statements.
NOTE CONF
And but once we get to an expression, they're definitely
all branching off each other.
NOTE CONF
When was I going with that?
Let's track of where I was going to that discussion.
NOTE CONF
Let me jump back over to my coat.
Welcome to Environments.
NOTE CONF
Can anyone remember what I was going that?
Well, you don't know where I was going, but we
NOTE CONF
talk about environments.
They make maps to particulate in different positions.
NOTE CONF
Oh, yes, we were talking about the compile time runtime
difference.
NOTE CONF
So the phases we did so far we took in
the character stream and send it to the scanner.
NOTE CONF
And that gave us the tokens stream.
And we sent it to pasa.
NOTE CONF
And that gave us an A ST like we've got
above.
NOTE CONF
So from here there are some other compile time things
I might like to do, and the one I just
NOTE CONF
mentioned checking that a variable is declared before it's used.
It's called name analysis, and another thing I might like
NOTE CONF
to do checking that a variable is only used in
a place where it's allowed to be used might be
NOTE CONF
called type analysis, and these are checks that JACC does
for you.
NOTE CONF
Um, but we haven't talked about here in this course.
And eventually, after doing all those checks, we might eventually
NOTE CONF
then wanna run the programme.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
So the key is in that diagram.
All of those things happen on the abstract syntax tree,
NOTE CONF
which means all of them are ultimately a tree visiting
algorithm.
NOTE CONF
Which means if we were going to implement name analysis
just to check for variable declaration before use, we would
NOTE CONF
do it full controversial using another visitor, um, and end
up just doing a small part of what we're gonna
NOTE CONF
do in the interpreter anyway.
So in the book, they just say, Look, we're just
NOTE CONF
gonna do this in the interpreter, because that makes more
sense.
NOTE CONF
We're doing it in the interpreter.
Anyway, it would be weird in a book like this
NOTE CONF
to say this small part of what the interpreter does,
I'm gonna pull out and do separately in another phase.
NOTE CONF
But with other things like this, there might be reasons
to do other steps on the abstract syntax tree before
NOTE CONF
we run the interpreter directly.
But in most cases, those things I it's possible to
NOTE CONF
bundle them up into the interpreter and you end up
with a little bit more spaghetti in your coat.
NOTE CONF
Maybe you end up with more runtime errors than compile
time errors.
NOTE CONF
But you still have kind of simplified the thing, which
is what we're aiming for here.
NOTE CONF
So we're gonna do both those at the same time.
We're gonna keep track of which variables exist at any
NOTE CONF
point in the programme.
And what the values of those variables are at that
NOTE CONF
point in the programme.
Yeah, Cool.
NOTE CONF
Can you see how well actually we write those out?
So which variables this at any point?
NOTE CONF
What value?
At any point.
NOTE CONF
So which values exist at any point in the programme?
And what are the values of those variables?
NOTE CONF
At any point in the programme, this one you could
do with a quick pass over the programme because you
NOTE CONF
just need to look for anything that's got a decal
decal, decal.
NOTE CONF
This one you can't do without fully evaluating, because one
of these decals might have a big complicated expression on
NOTE CONF
the right hand side.
And you're gonna have to do basically you gonna have
NOTE CONF
to evaluate the programme to work it out anyway.
Or it might mention another variable that was earlier.
NOTE CONF
And so you've got to evaluate that variable to get
there.
NOTE CONF
So, out of the two things we're doing here, one
is possibly static.
NOTE CONF
The other is definitely dynamic.
But we're doing them both dynamically cool.
NOTE CONF
And the process of looking at an interpreter like this
and splitting out that and being precise about it hopefully
NOTE CONF
helps you understand other programming better.
Alright, So this interpreter is actually gonna visit these statements
NOTE CONF
in order 12, three for And so I used the
language before.
NOTE CONF
We tend to want to know the value.
We wanna know what the environment is before the statement
NOTE CONF
after the statement, and that'll fill in the value of
the environment in all places.
NOTE CONF
So the environment in this place is empty.
The environment in this place is excused to kind of
NOTE CONF
squeeze it in.
But you'll see what I mean.
NOTE CONF
X three, the environment in this place, there's also X
three and then the environment in this place X three,
NOTE CONF
Y five and the environment in this place X three
Y five.
NOTE CONF
All right, so that's our diagrammatic interpretation of what's going
on with environments.
NOTE CONF
And you're like, Oh, man, It's so easy.
All I'm doing is adding a variable in the environment
NOTE CONF
and look how much stuff he's drawn on the screen.
Um, but to me, it's really important to know wh
NOTE CONF
wh Why that thing is there Questions.
OK, cool.
NOTE CONF
So what's this gonna be look like in an interpreter?
It's just gonna look like every time I see a
NOTE CONF
variable declaration, just add that thing to the environment.
So I better be keeping track of this environment.
NOTE CONF
And I can see from my diagram that there's gonna
have to be some kind of new variable inside the
NOTE CONF
interpreter class.
I might just directly use myself Uh uh, one of
NOTE CONF
the Java hash maps or something.
The text chooses to make a separate environment class.
NOTE CONF
That is basically just a hash map.
But it does that so that it can customise the
NOTE CONF
way you look into the hash map.
And also because there's another trick coming that I'll explain
NOTE CONF
soon.
OK, so easy enough for a programme like that.
NOTE CONF
Um, we haven't done functions yet, but we are about
to introduce a kind of function like thing called a
NOTE CONF
block, so you'll be used to functions or you're used
to something like a a FA Y loop right where
NOTE CONF
you go.
Wow, X is less than 10.
NOTE CONF
And what was the syntax in what was the syntax?
Um, print XX equals X plus one, right.
NOTE CONF
You'll be used to that.
You'll also be used to the fact that you can
NOTE CONF
say VY equals X and print Y, and that'll work
as well.
NOTE CONF
It's a stupid thing to do, but that'll work as
well and that the thing you're used to there is
NOTE CONF
that that far Y doesn't exist down here.
It's got the scope.
NOTE CONF
So environments have to implement scope as well and to
make things simpler at this point, we're actually just introducing
NOTE CONF
these things called blocks, which we've already mentioned before because
we did them in Ruby and they had a similar
NOTE CONF
syntax and we're now gonna do them In Scala.
A block is just a way to group up a
NOTE CONF
bunch of code.
We use parentheses to group up expressions, and we use
NOTE CONF
blocks to group up statements.
And if you're comfortable with that once you're comfortable with
NOTE CONF
the idea that, um, curly braces introduce a block of
statements, a way to bundle up statements gives you another
NOTE CONF
way to think about the syntax.
So when you thought about a wall loop, you thought
NOTE CONF
I put the wild keyword.
Then I put the condition and then I open up
NOTE CONF
parentheses.
And then I put all the statements that go in
NOTE CONF
that wild block.
I think of it differently.
NOTE CONF
I think of it as the wild keyword, then a
Boolean expression and then a block.
NOTE CONF
And that block well or in fact, just a statement.
And just like I can put a big, complicated, parenthesized
NOTE CONF
expression anywhere, I can put a single expression.
I can also put a big, complicated parenthesized statement anywhere
NOTE CONF
where I put one statement.
But the way I parenthesize statements is with the curly
NOTE CONF
braces instead of the round braces.
Nice.
NOTE CONF
And that's actually gonna work really great for a parser,
right?
NOTE CONF
If you have a way to pass something with a
block, you can just reuse that over and you can
NOTE CONF
use it for Wis and you can use it for
ifs and you can use it for functions because they
NOTE CONF
all have the same situation.
All they're really doing is saying the statement I wanna
NOTE CONF
run is actually a compound statement, not an individual statement.
So we're gonna introduce those block that block idea and
NOTE CONF
because in all those spaces we need the block to
introduce new scope.
NOTE CONF
We're also gonna make sure that this block just sitting
here by itself introduces new scope.
NOTE CONF
So this here can be thought of as a single
statement made up of three other statements.
NOTE CONF
So we've already worked out what the environment is on
line nine.
NOTE CONF
The environment is that X points to three and Y
points to five.
NOTE CONF
But what's the environment on?
I'll add one more.
NOTE CONF
What's the environment line?
That's why nine.
NOTE CONF
I'll put some more spaces in so that we can
see again.
NOTE CONF
What's the environment on line 11?
Exactly the same as line nine?
NOTE CONF
That's right.
Nothing's changed on the environment.
NOTE CONF
What's the environment in length?
13.
NOTE CONF
And it was three language.
Yeah, so that's a suggestion.
NOTE CONF
The suggestion was I'm gonna add this into my diagram
now, and it's a good suggestion.
NOTE CONF
Put this out to G was mentioning not Y Y.
Yeah, and that's the key.
NOTE CONF
That's the key, right?
So now I've added to my programme another statement Over
NOTE CONF
here.
I'll give it a bit of space.
NOTE CONF
This statement is one of these blocks, so it's actually
made up of three other statements.
NOTE CONF
OK, now the first statement I had, there was a
decal running out of space.
NOTE CONF
This always happens when you do these trees.
Was it Deco?
NOTE CONF
And it was a decco of why To X.
And then who can remember my second statement?
NOTE CONF
It was print Y.
Yes.
NOTE CONF
So that was a print statement with a Y.
And then my third statement was a binary operator with
NOTE CONF
plus X and one OK, so this is what my
tree looks like now.
NOTE CONF
So I want you to notice that in between each
statement, I needed an environment, so I'm probably gonna need
NOTE CONF
an environment here, and I'm gonna need an environment here
and here, but this one's gonna be the same as
NOTE CONF
this one.
And this one's gonna be the same as this one.
NOTE CONF
So let's just redraw that as we're actually going to
have a statement.
NOTE CONF
An environment here?
Yeah, yeah, here.
NOTE CONF
So the question I asked was, what's the environment on
this first one?
NOTE CONF
And one answer was that it was X is already
in the environment, and that was three Y was already
NOTE CONF
in the environment.
But I actually didn't.
NOTE CONF
It was five before, but I just updated it to
be X.
NOTE CONF
So it's three.
And then in between, I can fill in the statements
NOTE CONF
that causes a problem once we get to hear, because
once we get to here, I want the environment ultimately
NOTE CONF
to go back to what it was before cos the
blocks finished and that knew why I created as a
NOTE CONF
problem.
It should go away.
NOTE CONF
And why should go back to five?
OK, so in between, there'll be various things Now.
NOTE CONF
This process of going back to the old version, um,
requires some logic.
NOTE CONF
It requires me to either memorise that five so I
can reset it later.
NOTE CONF
Or it requires me to do what the book actually
does and what everybody actually does, which is nest environments
NOTE CONF
inside each other.
So, in reality, what we do here is we say
NOTE CONF
that anytime we see curly braces, it introduces a new
scope which introduces a new environment.
NOTE CONF
But that new environment is related to the old environment.
So an X three Y five and it'll have some
NOTE CONF
child environment which has Y three.
So once you get into a block, the environment's kind
NOTE CONF
of breed.
So now environments have to be not just a a
NOTE CONF
hash table.
They gotta be a hash table, plus the parent environment
NOTE CONF
in case they ever need to go back to it.
So I can probably start to fill these in now
NOTE CONF
from my memory of the programme.
So on this one, Oh no, that's a lie.
NOTE CONF
Sorry, this one's wrong.
At this point, there's a new environment that's a sub
NOTE CONF
child, but nothing's happened.
It's just a sub child empty, ready to roll.
NOTE CONF
It's not until I do the declaration down here that
I get that new one, but, yes, I'm gonna have
NOTE CONF
to draw over the top, and I apologise for that.
It's after that declaration that the Y, set to three,
NOTE CONF
has appeared in the new, smaller environment, but the original
environment's remained untouched.
NOTE CONF
And then the last one here, the X.
So after this line where I printed why nothing changed
NOTE CONF
at my moment.
And then after I ran this statement where X equals
NOTE CONF
X plus one, uh, I haven't quite got that binary
up right, by the way.
NOTE CONF
It's actually an assignment with a binary up inside it.
So, uh, excuse my error there after that statement, The
NOTE CONF
new environment is actually X three Y five Y three.
Well, there's only one When I did.
NOTE CONF
X equals X plus one.
There's only one X in this system.
NOTE CONF
So I have to have updated this one above, Not
the one.
NOTE CONF
And so X is actually going to four in that
environment.
NOTE CONF
So that's what I'm aiming for.
So what mechanics is gonna give me this?
NOTE CONF
The mechanics that is gonna give me this is a
a sub environment on new block and B check newest
NOTE CONF
block first, then go up.
So when I'm looking for a variable in my code,
NOTE CONF
I go to my environment.
I've only got one of them, but they're they're nested,
NOTE CONF
and I say, Ah, I've just done something with the
Y and I've just done something with the X.
NOTE CONF
So what's the value of Y?
I look in the smallest environment first, I can't point
NOTE CONF
on this version because you can't see my finger.
Um I look at the smallest environment first, which is
NOTE CONF
this one, and I get a value for why?
And so I go I.
NOTE CONF
I know what it is.
And here I say I need to know it's in
NOTE CONF
X.
I look in the smallest environment and there is no
NOTE CONF
X.
So I try the next environment up and I go,
NOTE CONF
Ah, X equals three.
So now I can do this.
NOTE CONF
I know that that variable is gonna get the number
three and then when I'm over here, I want to
NOTE CONF
print the Y.
So I look in the closest environment and I find
NOTE CONF
a Y equal three.
So I know to print over here I want to
NOTE CONF
do XXX plus one.
So I look in the closest environment and there is
NOTE CONF
no X.
So I go up to the environment above to know
NOTE CONF
which X I'm talking about.
So all of this is just doing exactly what you've
NOTE CONF
all been doing in your head the entire time.
But the way we get the interpreter to codify this,
NOTE CONF
though, is to have this set of nested environments look
just like a linked list, right?
NOTE CONF
And because it looks just like a link list.
How do you terminate this by saying, if you want
NOTE CONF
to say you're the top environment because every environment has
to have a parent well, the top environment's parent is
NOTE CONF
null, and that's my symbol for now.
So, in fact, even back here when we were doing
NOTE CONF
simpler ones, our environments had, uh, a parent environment.
But it was just now, OK, now, the other cool
NOTE CONF
thing about this mechanism is that it deals with that
name analysis problem.
NOTE CONF
So how do I know that I've tried to use
a variable before?
NOTE CONF
I've declared it.
If I'm going through this Well, sorry.
NOTE CONF
A part of this should be.
See, decal declarations add to newest environment.
NOTE CONF
Wherever I see a declaration, it gets added to the
newest environment.
NOTE CONF
I don't go looking further up.
Um, so if I'm looking for a variable and I
NOTE CONF
look in the newest environment, that's not there, I'll go
up and look in the highest environment, the higher one,
NOTE CONF
and look for it.
And if I'm still going upwards and I hit No,
NOTE CONF
I know I've hit a variable that was never declared.
And now I've got a nice, clear way to work
NOTE CONF
that out.
Alright, so here's all the mechanics I need to do
NOTE CONF
environments in a imperative language with blocks.
All right.
NOTE CONF
Questions?
No.
NOTE CONF
So this is not groundbreaking.
Don't I want you all to know that this is
NOTE CONF
just what you've done in your head?
All we're doing is creating a programme that does what
NOTE CONF
we all did when we learnt scope back in whenever
we learned scope.
NOTE CONF
But we're having to iron out every little corner detail
and think through what the consequences of that are.
NOTE CONF
And also we just had enough in our head last
week to try and cram another thing in.
NOTE CONF
So we saved this pretty simple kind of concept, conceptually
simple.
NOTE CONF
But, you know, there's a bit of code to to
mess with here.
NOTE CONF
OK, just check.
If anyone's been pinging me, I can't see No.
NOTE CONF
OK, so he goes through all those he goes through,
How you're gonna do that?
NOTE CONF
Uh, it's worth noting that he does the right thing,
which is when he declares a variable.
NOTE CONF
He uses the highest possible super type as the type
of that variable.
NOTE CONF
But when he creates the variable, he uses the exact
subtype that he wants because there are multiple types of
NOTE CONF
maps you could use in in Java.
So this all works if you put hash map over
NOTE CONF
here instead, it's just bad programming style.
Uh, so this is the new environment file.
NOTE CONF
You've made a whole separate environment class just to do
that.
NOTE CONF
And for now, it's just gonna store those.
It's just gonna replicate the kind of things you do
NOTE CONF
to environments you put values in and you get values
out.
NOTE CONF
Um, but later on, those put and gets are gonna
get more complicated because when you put a variable into
NOTE CONF
an environment, simple, when you get a variable out in
the environment, you get it.
NOTE CONF
If it's there or if it's not there you go
looking in the parent.
NOTE CONF
So that doesn't exist when he first writes this out.
But when he gets further down, it does, uh, so
NOTE CONF
that is let's go to the final get just break
down the scope down here.
NOTE CONF
This is all the nesting and shadowing we spoke about.
And that's if I talk about an environment cactus.
NOTE CONF
This is what I mean.
Um, because you can ultimately get a kind of cactus
NOTE CONF
upside entry diagram, um, of the environments.
I just want to get to his git.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, not very helpful.
So if you're looking, I should have just gone to
NOTE CONF
the original code.
I'll jump check back over to the code P environment
NOTE CONF
Java Gate.
So once you finally write out the full environment, it's
NOTE CONF
gonna have a hash map for its the values that
that environments storing it's gonna have the environment for the
NOTE CONF
parent environment.
When you first set it up, it's gonna be null
NOTE CONF
if it's the global environment.
And if you're setting up a sub environment, then you
NOTE CONF
set it up with the enclosing environment.
And when you try to get a value out of
NOTE CONF
the environment, you look for it.
Is it in my hash map?
NOTE CONF
If it is, then I'll return it.
But if it's not in my hash map, I'll return
NOTE CONF
it from whoever's above me.
Unless on the global environment, which is when the one
NOTE CONF
above me is null.
So then you're gonna drop down to this and you've
NOTE CONF
got yourself your undefined variable error.
OK, go bananas Cos so we've now got we now
NOTE CONF
know what a decal wants to do.
A decal wants to go into the environment and add
NOTE CONF
a new rapping.
So the the function that he's put in the environment
NOTE CONF
for dealing with that is called defy, and that's the
one you're gonna call anytime you see a decal.
NOTE CONF
Wow.
But we haven't actually dealt.
NOTE CONF
We haven't actually looked at assignment yet.
We did variable declaration, which set up a value we
NOTE CONF
did variable use.
I'm just gonna look at it and just go find
NOTE CONF
the right variable.
We'll talk a little bit more about variable assignment now.
NOTE CONF
OK, so reminder we saw decals, which are very simple
because a decal always declares a variable.
NOTE CONF
Uh, now, in this language locks because it's got classes.
Variable use can be more complicated than just an identifier.
NOTE CONF
So let's think about I'll draw my diagram.
I'll get my diagram back up.
NOTE CONF
The I know it's not up yet.
We'll get there so you can think about Java if
NOTE CONF
you need a more concrete example.
But the same thing is true of locks.
NOTE CONF
Every single time I write V something, and I either
put a semicolon there or I do V.
NOTE CONF
Something equals something.
Uh, semi colon.
NOTE CONF
The only thing that can go in this slot is
an identifier.
NOTE CONF
Just a single X or a Y or a X
is the variable where it is.
NOTE CONF
It's just a verbal name which we've been calling identifier.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
OK, but what can go on the left hand side
of an assignment later in the programme?
NOTE CONF
Well, obviously an identifier could go there.
X equals five is just fine, but I'm also able
NOTE CONF
to do things like object dot X equals five.
And if I've got a fully object oriented language like
NOTE CONF
Ruby, I might wanna even be able to write one
plus three dot Um, let's go with magnitude so we
NOTE CONF
might have a magnitude on an integer.
Um, that's not going in an assignment, but that might
NOTE CONF
go in a variable use position.
So identifier up here nice and simple.
NOTE CONF
That's what we did before, but down here, much more
complicated The things that can go on the left hand
NOTE CONF
side of an equals or can go in the place
where I might use a variable.
NOTE CONF
But let's just think about the left hand side of
an equals.
NOTE CONF
Uh, is more complicated.
So how to go about parsing that?
NOTE CONF
The book says we're gonna do a good trick.
We're gonna pause and check.
NOTE CONF
We're gonna pause a very broad range of things and
check.
NOTE CONF
So I'm just gonna I'm gonna pass that as if
it was an expression, not an identifier, which is gonna
NOTE CONF
allow a bunch of things I don't want.
And then after I've passed it as, uh, an expression,
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna do a check to make sure that it
was really something that could be in a in that
NOTE CONF
slot, which means the top of it has to be
a, uh, an identifier of some sort.
NOTE CONF
So we go through that explanation of how to do
the pas and check.
NOTE CONF
So that's what this section 841 is about disign syntax.
It shows a few examples and shows the way that
NOTE CONF
he does it.
So the way that he does it is if we're
NOTE CONF
passing an assignment, then for sure, we're gonna pass the
left hand side as an expression and remember that the
NOTE CONF
top production for expression was a equality.
But that's really an expression.
NOTE CONF
And then after we've passed that, we're gonna try and
pass the equal symbol.
NOTE CONF
And then if we successfully pass the equal symbol, uh,
we're gonna go again because you can actually put E
NOTE CONF
equal.
You can in his language, you can in this language,
NOTE CONF
you can do, uh, X equals Y equals Z equals
three, and that'll make them all equal to three.
NOTE CONF
Um, so he does allow assignment again.
And then at the end, he says, OK, we gotta
NOTE CONF
check that thing you passed by way back then at
the start that's on the left hand side of the
NOTE CONF
equal symbol.
Please go check that That's actually an instance of a
NOTE CONF
variable, not an instance of some other expression we might
have got to.
NOTE CONF
And you're like, What was the point of that?
Why didn't this par expression?
NOTE CONF
Because sometimes a variable can have more complicated things below.
But the parser will ultimately put EXP dot variable at
NOTE CONF
the top when it's finished working out the entire variable.
Now for for us now, those variables are just variables.
NOTE CONF
But if we got to introduce in classes, variables would
be more complicated things.
NOTE CONF
OK, so that's what that section's about.
Any questions?
NOTE CONF
Any worries?
Any excitement?
NOTE CONF
Uh, I believe above here we talk about so there's
a little bit here about ex assignments being expressions, not
NOTE CONF
statements, and I'm not a huge fan of that.
So I'm I go into that a little bit more
NOTE CONF
with you in the class because from what we've seen
in the class in the language so far.
NOTE CONF
Anything that sits on a line by itself gets to
be an expression.
NOTE CONF
Anything that can be bundled up into other things gets
to be a statement.
NOTE CONF
My assignments are always sitting on lines by themselves, and
I said to you that expressions evaluate to something, and
NOTE CONF
as statements do, something feels very much like an assignment.
Just does something changes the environment.
NOTE CONF
Um, it's a natural fit to be a statement, and
all logic tells us it should be a statement.
NOTE CONF
But some programming language history means that it's an expression.
And the short answer is that, um, you know, C
NOTE CONF
allowed it to be an expression.
So many people think of it an expression.
NOTE CONF
Now it does.
If it's an expression, it does allow you to do
NOTE CONF
that.
Variable A equals B equals C equals five.
NOTE CONF
You couldn't do that if it was a statement, could
you?
NOTE CONF
Um, because you just have to have variables.
A equals five variable.
NOTE CONF
B equals five variables.
C equals five.
NOTE CONF
Um, but we're not gonna follow.
We're not gonna worry about the logic of it.
NOTE CONF
We're just gonna say Oh, it is it's an expression,
not a statement.
NOTE CONF
But that means I can put it anywhere.
An expression goes, and it also means it has to
NOTE CONF
return a value.
So what's the return value of a statement?
NOTE CONF
So the return value of an assignment expression cos that
that's a That's a, um sorry.
NOTE CONF
This here is a statement, for sure, cos it's created
a new variable.
NOTE CONF
But we're talking about this assignment by itself that looks
like a statement.
NOTE CONF
But in reality he's saying, This is gonna be one
of those expression statements where the expression inside it is
NOTE CONF
an assignment expression, which has why on the left and
four on the right, So that's what he's aiming for,
NOTE CONF
Um, but because it's sitting in an expression slot, it
better have a value.
NOTE CONF
What's the value of the expression gonna be so kind
of, uh, whatever.
NOTE CONF
Whatever you find.
Yep, the two candidates are nil or four.
NOTE CONF
There's only one variable in this, only one value in
this damn thing.
NOTE CONF
Um, so we either have to choose nil or four
and then choose four cool, so that gets covered.
NOTE CONF
And that's why it goes in the expression part of
the language.
NOTE CONF
not in the other part, and that's why we add
it to the expression part of the A ST generator.
NOTE CONF
And that's why assignment is in the expression part of
the Parsa.
NOTE CONF
OK, then that's the stuff I spoke about before.
So what's the semantics of an assignment?
NOTE CONF
Well, when I say semantics, I mean, what does the
interpreter do when he gets to it?
NOTE CONF
Well, when an interpreter gets to an assignment, it's gonna
get there in an expression I've already explained to you
NOTE CONF
what the Although we haven't written it up, I've already
explained to you what the interpreter should do for a
NOTE CONF
declaration.
It should go to the environment and add that.
NOTE CONF
And I told you what the interpreter should do for
a variable use.
NOTE CONF
It should look in the newest environment and then look
in the next newest and then give up.
NOTE CONF
What should I do for an assignment?
Pretty much what we just said for use except then
NOTE CONF
also update the the environment should look in the smallest.
If you can't find it, you should look in the
NOTE CONF
next one, so we have to.
But before we do that, we have to evaluate the
NOTE CONF
entirety of what's on the right hand side of the
assignment.
NOTE CONF
In my example, it was just the number four, but
it could have been arbitrarily complex.
NOTE CONF
So that whole thing gets evaluated first.
Then that whole thing gets put into the environment at
NOTE CONF
that location and we're gonna use the helper function from
environment to do the hard work and the helper function
NOTE CONF
from the environment says, Alright, alright, I'm the newest environment.
If I've got that key already, I will update it.
NOTE CONF
At this point, I'm gonna give an error.
But later on, I'm also gonna when I, uh I'm
NOTE CONF
gonna try it on the on the parent as well,
Which is what the scope stuff he does.
NOTE CONF
So that updates the nesting and the shadowing.
That's the block syntax.
NOTE CONF
Oh, so he also explains how to add block syntax.
A block is a, um comes out like a single
NOTE CONF
expression.
But it is a list of sorry statement, but is
NOTE CONF
a list of statements.
This is one where he says it can include other
NOTE CONF
declarations.
So he chooses the declaration part of the of the
NOTE CONF
grammar instead of the expression place, Remember In his version,
he separated declaration from statement.
NOTE CONF
And so there was a There's a production above this
one that says Declaration, is either a V decal or
NOTE CONF
a statement, and obviously you want to allow decals inside
a block.
NOTE CONF
So that's why it says decal star there, um, we
also have to add that block to the new abstract
NOTE CONF
syntax tree.
Uh, and so I didn't do that in my diagram.
NOTE CONF
I just put a single statement and drew lines to
it.
NOTE CONF
But that single statement I put there should have been
a block statement.
NOTE CONF
Uh, the passing of it's pretty simple.
And yeah, so it works exactly the way you'd expect.
NOTE CONF
Once you see a left brace, you start parsing a
block.
NOTE CONF
Once you get into a block, you just keep parsing
statements until you get to a right brace and then
NOTE CONF
you're done.
And then the the semantics for, um, what the interpreter
NOTE CONF
should do when it gets to a block statement is
it should evaluate each statement one by one.
NOTE CONF
So he writes a separate function for doing that called
Execute block, but notes also, when he executes the block,
NOTE CONF
he fires up a brand new environment, especially for that
block.
NOTE CONF
That's got the old environment within it.
And so execute Block, then is doing most of the
NOTE CONF
hard work.
But all it's doing is just looping through the statements
NOTE CONF
it does.
One extra thing is that it grabs the environment at
NOTE CONF
the start in case there is a, um, error so
it can restore the environment.
NOTE CONF
Uh, I don't think we'd actually come across that that
situation in our own code, but we can believe that's
NOTE CONF
a nice thing to do because any of these statements
might throw an error.
NOTE CONF
Cool.
Oh, no, that's what he does.
NOTE CONF
Sorry, we're inside the interpreter inside the interpreter and the
interpreter's only got a single global variable that's keeping track
NOTE CONF
of the environment.
So we say, Oh, I'm an interpreter is about to
NOTE CONF
execute a block.
So I've gotta swap out the I.
NOTE CONF
I've first got to memorise the parent environment I was
working with.
NOTE CONF
Then I've gotta swap that out for this new environment
I've just been given, which is the fresh one that
NOTE CONF
is a child.
And then at the end of all of this, no
NOTE CONF
matter what happens, I've gotta turf that one with the
child and go back to the one I had before.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, so he's memorising the reference to the environment.
And that's got to do with the fact that there's
NOTE CONF
a single interpreter, uh, with a global variable that's storing
the current environment that the execution context wants to use.
NOTE CONF
And so, yeah, that simple concept from the start is
getting more and more complicated.
NOTE CONF
We're having to deal with little age cases here again.
Uh, and then he got some example programmes to show
NOTE CONF
it off.
OK, questions.
NOTE CONF
OK, so yeah, go ahead and implement that in your
and write a bunch of programmes to test it.
NOTE CONF
Open up scopes, close scopes.
Do weird things in the scopes.
NOTE CONF
Try out assignments as expressions in weird places, which is
a bit hard to do right now.
NOTE CONF
Cos in the weirdest places normally involve loops and stuff.
It talks a little bit about some design decisions.
NOTE CONF
Um, a fairly common one in dynamic languages is that
you don't have a separate declaration phase.
NOTE CONF
You only have assignments, and if you're assigned to a
variable that doesn't exist, it just causes the variable to
NOTE CONF
exist.
Uh, there's a lot of reasons why we might want
NOTE CONF
that enough good reasons that people keep making that design
mistake, but it's a design mistake.
NOTE CONF
Um, it's too easy to put a typo in your
left hand side of your variable assignment and find yourself
NOTE CONF
creating a variable instead of using one that you already
thought existed.
NOTE CONF
Um, so as an example, an area that comes up
all the time in Python is Maybe I've got, um
NOTE CONF
the place to store things equals new.
I don't need new in Python, but whatever it is
NOTE CONF
OK, and then a whole bunch of code goes on
and then I wanna update the place to store things.
NOTE CONF
But I accidentally wrote it like this.
And now, instead of updating this variable up here that
NOTE CONF
I thought I was updating, I actually just create a
whole new variable.
NOTE CONF
This one stays the same, and I get a nasty
bug that's hard to find.
NOTE CONF
It's as if one of my lines of code just
didn't run.
NOTE CONF
And you're like, That's strange.
Uh, not a Not a great idea.
NOTE CONF
I don't think, uh, so Ruby does just do this
automatic introduction, but you've got this little game you've got
NOTE CONF
to play between local and global variables, which I don't
like any better to be honest.
NOTE CONF
And JavaScript does, uh, some, uh, strange things.
As always, assignment modifies an existing variable in any enclosing
NOTE CONF
scope if found.
If not, it introduces a new variable in the global
NOTE CONF
scope.
Not in the globe, not local scope.
NOTE CONF
You're just inside of, um, that.
Where might that have come from?
NOTE CONF
Has anyone got enough clues so far to find out
where that might have come from?
NOTE CONF
Damien might.
Can you guess?
NOTE CONF
Why would JavaScript have this rule?
Based on what we know about JavaScript's history, It's javascript
NOTE CONF
weird adherence to strange scheme like things.
Because Java, the guy who invented JavaScript, was kind of
NOTE CONF
writing his own scheme and kind of not.
And that's something that would happen.
NOTE CONF
That's something that would happen in scheme.
And so it happens in Java script as well.
NOTE CONF
But it makes no sense in the rest of the
language, whereas in scheme it makes some sense.
NOTE CONF
It just makes me think of that, that yeah Oh,
yeah.
NOTE CONF
OK, so the advantage to, uh, uh, implicit declaration simplicity.
The disadvantage is that it definitely introduces more bugs.
NOTE CONF
Um, and the concept of a declaration doesn't have to
be learned as someone who's taught programming to, uh I
NOTE CONF
don't know, maybe 20,000 people.
Uh, declaration has to be learned in every language, no
NOTE CONF
matter what.
Even if it's not in the syntax.
NOTE CONF
Uh, OK, I'll be more on that.
All right, there we go.
NOTE CONF
We are all good to go with statements of the
state now and nested bas uh, scopes.
NOTE CONF
So next week we move on to well, next week,
the week after the break, we move on to control
NOTE CONF
flow.
And so hopefully you can see now how control flow
NOTE CONF
is gonna grow very quickly from this situation.
We've already introduced the scopes that will allow us to
NOTE CONF
do the blocks from the control flow.
We don't have bullions yet.
NOTE CONF
Do we have bullions?
Do you have bullions now?
NOTE CONF
We've got bullions expressions so they'll be able to go
into the All we gotta do is work out how
NOTE CONF
to pause the while slash if four slash if and
then just work out what the interpreter is going to
NOTE CONF
do when it gets to them, which is probably not
going to be hard.
NOTE CONF
Sounds like fun.
And we will do control flow in one week.
NOTE CONF
Not two, and then we'll break up functions into two
weeks.
NOTE CONF
OK?
And now we move on to the awesome list of
NOTE CONF
Awesome, which is Scala.
We'll just break for any other questions.
NOTE CONF
Check online for any other questions.
Popped up in the last 10 seconds.
NOTE CONF
Oh, it was AJ SR in 10 days.
Uh, something like that.
NOTE CONF
I I've always thought that was a like most of
the things I wrote I wrote in 10 days, but
NOTE CONF
I wrote a really crappy version of them, and then
I spent three years making them work.
NOTE CONF
So it's a bit of a javascript having a bit
of a slack off at it.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
I think if someone said to like, if someone said
NOTE CONF
to you, when did you How long did it take
you to do your assignment?
NOTE CONF
You'd probably say, Oh, like two hours stand down Sunday
afternoon.
NOTE CONF
But really, it actually took you a lot longer than
that.
NOTE CONF
Um, there was more before there was more after there
was more going on.
NOTE CONF
Ra Ra Ra Ra ra.
It's like, Yeah, sure it didn't take that long to
NOTE CONF
stand tight.
Bit out.
NOTE CONF
Um, but yeah, yeah.
Lectures are the highest.
NOTE CONF
You know.
I agree.
NOTE CONF
Someone knows, Uh, the weight of my heart.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Alright, Scarlet, This time we will use the visualizer.
But it might just be for the people here, cos
NOTE CONF
I might be typing things on the on visual studio
more than anything else.
NOTE CONF
So this is to keep me on track with what
I want to talk about.
NOTE CONF
I think you can get a preview of the questions
you're gonna get asked.
NOTE CONF
Because, I, I was thinking up exam questions while I
was working through the book.
NOTE CONF
See?
Oh, you can't see.
NOTE CONF
I had no electronic device on me and I was
thinking of exam questions, See?
NOTE CONF
So I was scribbling them on my book.
I don't know if you get any useful clues from
NOTE CONF
them, though, and some of them are probably, uh, workshop
Christians anyway.
NOTE CONF
But anyway, sure, it won't give away too much, So
I think I'll code up scarlet in front of me.
NOTE CONF
I'll have the the book on the non projected screen
just so that I can keep track.
NOTE CONF
But for everyone else, you want to open the book
to chapter five?
NOTE CONF
Um, and we are just doing day one again.
So that gets us through to the end of the
NOTE CONF
castle on the hill.
Here we go.
NOTE CONF
And so specifically, he he covers.
He covers the idea that and the concept that it
NOTE CONF
wants to be a hybrid language between functional and object
oriented.
NOTE CONF
But he doesn't get deep into the functional side of
things.
NOTE CONF
He explains the the object or differences, Uh, in that
first chapter in that first day.
NOTE CONF
OK, so I, I believe.
OK, so Sara, unlike Java at the time it was
NOTE CONF
released, has a ripple.
An interpreter, which is that's a revelation in itself, um,
NOTE CONF
as a way to experiment with code and understand what's
going on in the system.
NOTE CONF
So Scara is Well, the interview here at the DURSI
is really good, and Dursi is a bit of a
NOTE CONF
hero of mine.
I think he did a really good job of merging
NOTE CONF
OO and functional, and most of the places you see
OO and functional merging.
NOTE CONF
I basically just used his ideas.
Uh, I mean, he did it with other people.
NOTE CONF
So desk is also responsible for generic sit java.
Um, so he's got a long history working with Java
NOTE CONF
and improving the object or side of things.
But at some point, whenever it was, I mean, I
NOTE CONF
think it was something like 2005 to the saying here.
He just was like, Bugger, I'll make my own language
NOTE CONF
But the ones who did 2000 would be I didn't
talk about it.
NOTE CONF
It's, uh Ah, pizza.
Yes.
NOTE CONF
Nice.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
So pizza was his version of Java that he made
with Waddle that got rolled into real Java.
NOTE CONF
They went, Oh, those are such good ideas.
We're doing those and so dusky trained as a functional
NOTE CONF
programmer and then found himself in the other world.
And so one of the reasons to a bit of
NOTE CONF
a hero is because my experience is quite similar to
his where I learned functional programming and I'm like, this
NOTE CONF
is the best thing ever.
And then I went out in the industry, and just
NOTE CONF
it didn't fit and functional.
Kept winning.
NOTE CONF
And everyone kept thinking function.
Uh, sorry.
NOTE CONF
Object owner kept winning, and I'm like, What am I
missing here?
NOTE CONF
Why am I the odd one out?
I'm like, uh, Skinner.
NOTE CONF
No, it's the Children that are wrong, right?
And And the being able to stand up and go.
NOTE CONF
Actually, maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe OO is the way.
NOTE CONF
And maybe what I need to do is make all
this functional, cool stuff work in OO.
NOTE CONF
It's not something very many people did.
Um, but he did, and we got Scarlett to thank
NOTE CONF
for it, but we got that to thank Scarlett for
So he brought in all the best ideas from functional
NOTE CONF
programming and made them work in object do.
And the way he did that was just saying, it's
NOTE CONF
gonna run on the JVM.
And for those who don't know, the JVM deep down
NOTE CONF
in its core is just objects.
It doesn't compile away the objects.
NOTE CONF
It compiles away a bunch of other stuff, but not
the objects.
NOTE CONF
So if you're gonna make something work on the JVM,
you're gonna turn it into objects.
NOTE CONF
So he took each of the functional Well, each of
the many concepts from that were out there and worked
NOTE CONF
out how to turn them into objects.
So he made an object translation for them, and more
NOTE CONF
specifically, AJ VM translation for them.
Uh, and along the way, made a much better version
NOTE CONF
of java as well.
By improving the way it works and the way the
NOTE CONF
improvements often come over from the functional world in a
way that other people weren't thinking of.
NOTE CONF
I don't think I really don't think they were thinking
of the one place where functional programming really was winning
NOTE CONF
as a concept was in concurrency.
And so the fact that Scala had all these mechanisms
NOTE CONF
meant that Scala had much better concurrency libraries than Java.
And to be honest, it probably still does.
NOTE CONF
I think most so.
Another part of it is that because it's written to
NOTE CONF
target the JVM perfectly, you can write Scala code and
run it from Java and you can write Java code
NOTE CONF
and run it from Scala.
So a lot of people were writing concurrent libraries in
NOTE CONF
Scala even if their users were running them from Java.
They were still choosing Scala as their way to to
NOTE CONF
to express what they want to express.
A bit of local history on Scala is that, um
NOTE CONF
it was what we taught this course in until last
year.
NOTE CONF
Um, and it took off quite big in Sydney, partly
because of a couple of, uh I guess large and
NOTE CONF
influential places that got into Scala early.
Uh, one was the, uh who was it up in
NOTE CONF
Brisbane.
So there was a group of people in Brisbane who
NOTE CONF
got right into Scala and created the cats library.
Um And so if you look up Scala, you'll find
NOTE CONF
cats is probably one of the top 10 libraries that
people know about.
NOTE CONF
And then down here in Sydney, Atlassian um spent a
lot of time.
NOTE CONF
They didn't transition to Scala.
They investigated transitioning to Scala.
NOTE CONF
And so they were employing Scala.
And a lot of the start-ups in Sydney were doing
NOTE CONF
the same.
Start-ups were, uh, all starting with Scala as their stack.
NOTE CONF
So Sydney became a well, Australia became one of the
centres, I guess of scalar development.
NOTE CONF
But it also became a bit of a thorn in
the side of the Scarlet developers because those Brisbane people
NOTE CONF
I were talking about were functional language.
Zealot and owski didn't like that.
NOTE CONF
He's like I did this because the functional programming zealotry
was the wrong idea.
NOTE CONF
And now you go around and telling all my scholar
programmers they got a programme in a functional style.
NOTE CONF
I'm not a big fan of you people.
Um but that's OK.
NOTE CONF
They they got they?
They just Everyone did their own thing.
NOTE CONF
Um, but the big in the start-ups all got bought
out and stopped.
NOTE CONF
When a start-up gets bought out, it stopped writing anything.
For those of you who don't know start-ups get bought
NOTE CONF
out, not for their IP and not for their code.
I don't know how the hell it works, but Start-ups
NOTE CONF
all got bought out.
And so the Scarlett development wasn't needed anymore.
NOTE CONF
At last, he had moved to C instead of scar
iron.
NOTE CONF
So Scarlett wasn't needed anymore.
And so, uh, it lost its reason it as a
NOTE CONF
resume filler, it lost its reason to exist.
So that's one of the reasons we've switched back to
NOTE CONF
Java.
If this book existed if the crafting interpreters book existed
NOTE CONF
in Scala, we just do that cos Scala's better.
But it only exists in Java.
NOTE CONF
So we couldn't, um, justify doing it otherwise.
But it's still, I think, out of all the kind
NOTE CONF
of it.
So it's back in the niche language land it went.
NOTE CONF
It went niche language and then went mainstream and then
dropped back into niche language.
NOTE CONF
But there's only 10 mainstream languages.
So unless you want to be really boring.
NOTE CONF
You're gonna learn yourself some niche languages and this one
I put top of the pile.
NOTE CONF
It's still the most useful.
The JVM is still absolutely everywhere, and so scarlet code
NOTE CONF
runs absolutely everywhere.
Interoperability with JB M is perfect.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so I would still recommend people learn it despite
all what I just did there.
NOTE CONF
And as OO programmers yourselves.
Because you've gone through a Java programme here, it makes
NOTE CONF
these other concepts much more accessible because you've got something
to hang them on.
NOTE CONF
And hopefully I'll show you a bit of that today.
Alright, so the rle is one thing that's very useful.
NOTE CONF
Um, concurrency.
The other thing it introduces.
NOTE CONF
That's very nice.
Java's now stolen.
NOTE CONF
So Java's stolen some of the concurrency stuff.
In fact, Java's stolen, I don't know, maybe 15% of
NOTE CONF
Scala.
Uh, and that's a very good thing for everybody.
NOTE CONF
That's another reason why it's less important to teach Scarlett
when Java's taken on all of those things anyway.
NOTE CONF
But it's only 15% and Scara still does them all
better because it it OK because it didn't try and
NOTE CONF
shoehorn it back into Java.
It started from scratch from the language point of view
NOTE CONF
and then shoehorned it The compiler did all the shoehorning
uh, right here programme in Java land programme is still
NOTE CONF
have to do a bit of the shoe morning.
OK, uh but another one is, uh type inference.
NOTE CONF
So in Scala, you don't have to say the type
of your variables very often.
NOTE CONF
You can get away with it a lot and that's
nice.
NOTE CONF
Everything is an object in Scala W.
Why?
NOTE CONF
Why wouldn't everything be an object immediately in Java?
I mean, we've had Ruby's got everything as an object.
NOTE CONF
IO has got everything as an object.
Now Scar's doing everything as an object.
NOTE CONF
It's cool to be able to do things like they
have here in the book where you do What are
NOTE CONF
we doing?
We're doing well.
NOTE CONF
That's just funny Syntax, Can I do this?
I don't think that'll work.
NOTE CONF
No, cos size is not a member of in T.
Uh, I don't know what is a member meant That
NOTE CONF
one is, um so that's me just showing you everything
as an object that just two string is not a
NOTE CONF
yes, for one.
I just got to think of something, but that's just
NOTE CONF
nice to be able to do.
Right.
NOTE CONF
So why doesn't every language do it?
I can guess.
NOTE CONF
No guesses.
I'm gonna wait for a guess.
NOTE CONF
Yes, in the not exactly.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
Efficiency.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
And I hate to pick on you, but perform it
is a word that I've got a problem with.
NOTE CONF
Um, the reason is because it so I'll give you
this little spiel just for the fun of it.
NOTE CONF
Uh, it mostly happens in the web field.
Um, Performant wraps up multiple words.
NOTE CONF
You might as well just use the word.
So we're talking about efficiency.
NOTE CONF
Runtime efficiency in particular.
Here A.
NOTE CONF
As programmers offered, we've got a trade off between runtime
efficiency and memory efficiency.
NOTE CONF
And so an overarching word that just tries to cover
both of them doesn't tell you which one you traded
NOTE CONF
off for.
But anyway, um, it's normally just meant it runs faster.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, but you're exactly right.
It runs slower.
NOTE CONF
Um, but not in scara.
Scarlet's got this really cool internal machinery, uh, called implicit,
NOTE CONF
which automatically converts to the fastest version.
And if you really want to be a scholar programme,
NOTE CONF
you gotta get your head around implicit.
Um, and one of the things I love about Scala
NOTE CONF
is that it gets the best of it, gets the
best of all worlds, and there's a cost to get
NOTE CONF
the best of all worlds, which is complexity.
But you get to dip in to the complexity as
NOTE CONF
you go and learn all the little complex nooks and
crannies bit by bit.
NOTE CONF
Way cool.
And that's the reason.
NOTE CONF
One of the reasons I mean scara became semi famous
because Twitter was originally written in Ruby on ruby on
NOTE CONF
rails, and when they were running out of performance on
the backend, they rewrote their backend in Scala and started
NOTE CONF
running very fast and I.
I don't know if Twitter's still on Scala, but it
NOTE CONF
may well be, uh, so that's why scar, uh, that's
when I first got some mindshare.
NOTE CONF
And because you could translate Rubi code almost, um, concept
for concept and leave scara to make it faster, whereas
NOTE CONF
Ruby couldn't get faster.
So internally, all this thing's doing integers the the the
NOTE CONF
faster ones when it can, and the slower ones when
it has to.
NOTE CONF
But everything's an object.
Um, we don't have to care about types.
NOTE CONF
I can just write VX equals one.
I don't And it worked out that one wants to
NOTE CONF
be a capital I integer.
It'll defer to the object version for me.
NOTE CONF
And so that's what I mean by type inference.
Scara mixes up the Java syntax quite a bit.
NOTE CONF
It still uses curly braces and things like that, but
it introduces types differently.
NOTE CONF
It uses different syntax for generics.
That's where it gets some wins because it customised the
NOTE CONF
syntax for the job it was doing, whereas Java is
still stuck on its old syntax trying to jam things
NOTE CONF
in.
But this is one.
NOTE CONF
It's not variable.
Sorry, not type space variable.
NOTE CONF
It's variable coon type, Uh, and that's a better way
to do types.
NOTE CONF
Just is function types have a really nice syntax as
well.
NOTE CONF
So I think I can do Yep.
So But I chose a bad one.
NOTE CONF
OK?
Oh, it's using the wrong syntax, but here I am,
NOTE CONF
in a single line, defining a function F.
And then it tells me, Oh, you define something called
NOTE CONF
Fu and its type is unit.
Look above it.
NOTE CONF
So I define something called X and its type was
in.
NOTE CONF
It's using the same syntax in Scala The difference between
variables and functions is very, very small.
NOTE CONF
They're basically unified concepts.
One a variable is a function that takes no arguments,
NOTE CONF
and a function is a function that does take arguments.
And then down there, I made F into a function
NOTE CONF
that took one argument and returned another value.
And that's syntax for that.
NOTE CONF
OK, but I want to show you the object stuff.
That's the real, uh, so expressions and conditions.
NOTE CONF
Oh, it's an expression based language, so the everything returns
a value.
NOTE CONF
And I did that right here.
So the the concepts we just learned today are exactly
NOTE CONF
the same.
In scarlet, Curly Brace introduces a block ends a block.
NOTE CONF
But I just told you an expression based language.
So a block has to be an expression, Um, and
NOTE CONF
in Scalea, the rule is the value of the expression
is the last expression in the block.
NOTE CONF
The value of a block is the last expression in
the block.
NOTE CONF
So by putting an X at the end, I just
see him saying Return X, And that looks like that
NOTE CONF
might feel like just one small thing.
But the way that builds your ability to to grow
NOTE CONF
syntax.
It's a much more composable syntax than STA.
NOTE CONF
Statements are very non composable.
So when you're trying to make your code look nice
NOTE CONF
or you're trying to shorten it or you're trying to
make your library feel more like a language of its
NOTE CONF
own, um, having a statement based language just badly gets
in your way.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so expression based languages are better, and Scarlett does
a really nice job of making it all work.
NOTE CONF
So the next thing the book talks about is loops,
OK?
NOTE CONF
And the key is that, Well, one thing is it
doesn't have a four loop like you used to.
NOTE CONF
You can only really do.
Uh, you can like bodge it up.
NOTE CONF
But four loops are all four each loops like he
used to in Java, and it allows you to do
NOTE CONF
that ruby trick we did where?
Because a function could take a block as its last
NOTE CONF
parameter, you could have a function that took in a
block, and then it did that block over and over.
NOTE CONF
Scarlet does the same trick because scara allows you to
pass.
NOTE CONF
Ruby let you pass a block around as a single
argument to a function scara lets you pass as many
NOTE CONF
blocks to as many parameters as you want.
Um, which is a functional programming thing.
NOTE CONF
It's in reality.
They're not called blocks.
NOTE CONF
Once you do that, you start to call them first
class functions and or Landers.
NOTE CONF
Uh, and so Scala's got a nicer notation for lambdas
and more flexible use of lambdas as well than Java
NOTE CONF
does and full type infer for Lambda, which is very
useful.
NOTE CONF
OK, let's explore these ranges and triples a bit as
a way of kind of talking a bit more about
NOTE CONF
Scala.
So that's over on page 124.
NOTE CONF
Just gonna leave it there.
Um, everything's an object.
NOTE CONF
Oh, the syntax.
That's right.
NOTE CONF
I didn't get to show you the cool syntax.
I haven't done that yet.
NOTE CONF
So one plus two is we We know that as
a binary operator, right?
NOTE CONF
If you're a parser, you're parsing that you've got a
special syntax rule for binary operators.
NOTE CONF
And you know that, um, if you see if you
see an expression so I'm just going back to locks,
NOTE CONF
right?
You can see an expression if you're pausing an expression
NOTE CONF
so this I'll come up with a number token then
a plus token, then a two token, right?
NOTE CONF
And I'm passing an expression.
And so I'll pause an expression on the left and
NOTE CONF
get back at number one, and I'll pause.
And then when I'm trying to pause the plus, I'll
NOTE CONF
go.
Ah, I must be doing a binary operator.
NOTE CONF
So I know that that one gets attached to that
one and I have to pause an expression on the
NOTE CONF
right.
Cool.
NOTE CONF
But then when I do function definitions like, um, the
pas I think of this is something entirely differently.
NOTE CONF
The pasa thinks of this as, um you know, I'm
passing the left hand side and I get an expression
NOTE CONF
I now see a dot So I've got a method
call.
NOTE CONF
So that goes on the left hand side of the
method call.
NOTE CONF
Now I have to pause a function call on the
right.
NOTE CONF
We haven't done this yet, but you can imagine it's
what you're gonna do.
NOTE CONF
Two separate, completely separate pasing thing.
Separate ways that the programmer has to think of what
NOTE CONF
they're doing.
Um, Scarlett does some cool tricks, and one called trigger
NOTE CONF
does is it says every time you put an object
and a space and a function.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna do that.
How can I put this?
NOTE CONF
Well, one.
Oops.
NOTE CONF
So in Scala, that and that are exactly identical.
Every time Scara sees an object and a method, it
NOTE CONF
says, Ah, you meant object dot Method.
And I go?
NOTE CONF
Yeah, sure, Why not?
So this is called syntactic sugar, and you should think
NOTE CONF
of it as a preparing phase.
The scanner goes through, and then the sugar phase goes
NOTE CONF
through, and you're like, Well, whatever.
I mean, it's not that much better than that.
NOTE CONF
But if you flow this through the language, add a
couple of other things, then what's one pa gonna mean?
NOTE CONF
Well, I just told you that the scanner, if the
thing's gonna go well, uh, well, that's an object.
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna just put them together.
And he said, That doesn't look like a function that's
NOTE CONF
an operator.
So you add an extra trick, which is that in
NOTE CONF
scale?
You don't necessarily have to have parameters on a function.
NOTE CONF
And he goes, Sure, I mean, it's just that's same
as one dot plus.
NOTE CONF
See, It's given me a runtime error because I'm missing
out a number, but that was identical to one dot
NOTE CONF
plus.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
So ultimately one plus two was actually this in Scala.
Dig down.
NOTE CONF
This is what Scarlet reads when I say one plus
two.
NOTE CONF
It says, Take the object one.
Call its plus method and send it a two.
NOTE CONF
You know, well, that seems weird, but that's actually how
a heap of objects on the languages work because it's
NOTE CONF
an underlying this underlying system of saying Forget operators.
There are no operators.
NOTE CONF
There's only functions.
In fact, forget functions.
NOTE CONF
There's only methods, is just simplifies everything.
You just write up methods and everything else comes from
NOTE CONF
it.
But if you're a programmer, you get annoyed writing this
NOTE CONF
all the time.
So the Scalar people said, Well, I'm just gonna introduce
NOTE CONF
one cool rule, this one cool trick, which is anytime
you put an object in a space, I'm gonna pretend
NOTE CONF
you put an object in a dot And then any
time that follows on with another argument, I'm going to
NOTE CONF
put it in parentheses.
And now all of a sudden, you get this.
NOTE CONF
You get you get the syntax, not just for the
plus, which is definitely an operator, but you get it
NOTE CONF
for any function you write?
OK, If the function takes no arguments, you can just
NOTE CONF
put it in like the two strings.
If the function takes an argument, you can just put
NOTE CONF
it in the middle without having to worry about the
parentheses and the dots.
NOTE CONF
Deal with it for you.
OK, so this syntactic sugar trick, the scarlet is very,
NOTE CONF
very cool, and it does it in a lot of
other places, but that's a nice fun example.
NOTE CONF
What happens if you do the two string without parenthesis?
Is that what you Yeah, well, I'm gonna have to
NOTE CONF
try it, because there's one place I always forget.
Yeah, there was a warning because, uh so I'm gonna
NOTE CONF
backfill the answer, which is that in scara zero parentheses,
functions and functions without parentheses were treated the same.
NOTE CONF
And in newer versions, they're gonna stop that.
So they've just given me a deprecation warning here, which
NOTE CONF
is good because the the rules on that one were
weird.
NOTE CONF
Ok, any questions?
Let's look at what objects look like in Scala.
NOTE CONF
Well, it's a class based object honoured language, so you
should be able to do this right?
NOTE CONF
Here's a cool thing that the rebel does um, if
I'm half if I open a curly brace or something,
NOTE CONF
it just says, Oh, you're only halfway through to finding
this thing.
NOTE CONF
I'll wait till you're finished.
So I had to find a class called Foo.
NOTE CONF
But if I wanted to make a class called flu
with a constructor, I might think of doing this right.
NOTE CONF
It doesn't like that one reason it doesn't like that
is in Scala.
NOTE CONF
The constructors are thought of differently.
So back up from thinking of constructors as methods or
NOTE CONF
functions.
And think of what you use a constructor for.
NOTE CONF
You've got a class and you want to build a
new version of it.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, So the constructor ends up being and you, what
do you always put in a constructor is you put
NOTE CONF
every one of the fields and then what does a
constructor do?
NOTE CONF
It just says this dot field equals field.
This dot field equals field because ultimately all we're ever
NOTE CONF
wanting to do is say, we've got a class.
It represents every single let's say we're doing a class
NOTE CONF
of, um, students.
The class represents every single student, and students differ via
NOTE CONF
their student.
I DS so I have to parameterize the class by
NOTE CONF
student ID.
So it's gonna have to be a field.
NOTE CONF
But really, all I'm saying is that once you tell
me a student, ID I can build you a student.
NOTE CONF
That's what a class says or it's the with our
environment with our environment that says once you tell me
NOTE CONF
my parent environment, I can build you an environment just
like a function says once you give me the numbers
NOTE CONF
one and two, I can add them together for you.
So if you think of constructors like that as a
NOTE CONF
constructor is just telling us which piece of information this
class needs to build an object.
NOTE CONF
All this constructive stuff stops making any sense at all
because I wouldn't it be better just to combine the
NOTE CONF
two together so they do it.
OK, so this is a class.
NOTE CONF
This looks very much like function syntax, right?
This is a class that says once you give me
NOTE CONF
a in, I can give you a food.
So the only difference with a function is that function
NOTE CONF
says, Won't you give me an in?
I can do the food here.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna give you an objective type food and guess
what?
NOTE CONF
That covers the constructor as well.
I've just defined the class name.
NOTE CONF
I've defined the constructor.
I've defined every field inside it.
NOTE CONF
And I've defined what the constructor should do, which is
just take that parameter and set it to the field.
NOTE CONF
Done.
I don't need any fields.
NOTE CONF
Any separate constructors done much smarter away.
So many people would say, Well, then you say.
NOTE CONF
But what if I need overloaded constructors?
Sure, there's a way to do that.
NOTE CONF
Not a big deal, but most of your classes can
be done this way.
NOTE CONF
This also pays off again somewhere else.
Let's say let's do Let's do the odd shape.
NOTE CONF
You know how we might do a shape?
And we say that a square inherits from a rectangle,
NOTE CONF
Um, where the size are the same.
So I'm gonna make a class rectangle, and it's got
NOTE CONF
a width in and a height in there you go
to find the whole thing.
NOTE CONF
Constructors.
Good.
NOTE CONF
And then I wanted to find a square so I
can make one of these.
NOTE CONF
By the way, X equals new rectangle.
54 uh, not rectangle.
NOTE CONF
Oh, cos I already did X somewhere else.
I gotta do VA rectangle.
NOTE CONF
OK, so then R dot width exists.
Maybe not.
NOTE CONF
They cool.
You have a random mistake there.
NOTE CONF
I guess they're hidden unless I make them visible.
No hidden.
NOTE CONF
OK, but ours a rectangle.
Um, if I wanted to make a square, there was
NOTE CONF
a subclass of a rectangle in a normal language like
Java.
NOTE CONF
I'd do class square extends rectangle and then I'd have
to write a constructor for square that called the constructor
NOTE CONF
for rectangle.
And I always wanted to do that.
NOTE CONF
Well, Scholar's got a much nicer notation.
It says class square side in extends, rectangle side side
NOTE CONF
done all in the top line.
All in the definition that says, if you give me
NOTE CONF
a side, I can give you a square.
I also can say that that'll extend a rectangle with
NOTE CONF
being given the two sides together.
And when I press enter, they'll probably give me a
NOTE CONF
syntax error because I don't know, I got syntax just
right.
NOTE CONF
Oh, no, Perfect.
There you go.
NOTE CONF
So that approach to objects slash classes is way, way
better way, way better and just a straight up win.
NOTE CONF
Everybody should do that.
I can't see why anybody wouldn't but you can obviously
NOTE CONF
still put methods in there.
Oops.
NOTE CONF
Our system got out.
Um, so there you can see me calling directly the
NOTE CONF
unders.
I got it wrong.
NOTE CONF
But the underlying Java library there, you can see me
defining a a method.
NOTE CONF
I don't have to say what the method returns.
Scara works that out for me.
NOTE CONF
Works out that this one returns unit.
Uh, unit is the type in scara that goes with
NOTE CONF
void in java.
Well, I don't know about you, but it's just find
NOTE CONF
it much, much neater and much, much nicer way to
do things.
NOTE CONF
Ok, uh, what else do I wanna talk about?
On the object side of things extended, Uh, companion objects.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
So just give me a second.
NOTE CONF
I'll be back in one second, and then we'll do
companion objects.
NOTE CONF
Um, just gotta make a quick pit stop.
Hm?
NOTE CONF
Bear with me for three minutes.
Three minutes is right.
NOTE CONF
OK, so next up is instance methods, so you'll be
used to static methods because you've written one for every
NOTE CONF
single java programme you've ever written.
Static void main is a static method.
NOTE CONF
You don't have to create a main object to run
the main method on it.
NOTE CONF
We've got that in our locks.
Uh, Wick eight.
NOTE CONF
Whatever.
Wick five found drops.
NOTE CONF
OK, so the public class locks as a public static
void.
NOTE CONF
Main just means that you can run capital.
L locks dot um main and it fires up.
NOTE CONF
You don't have to do a new main object first.
Uh, this static methods on objects have always been a
NOTE CONF
funny fit in the object donated world.
They kind of there because they have to be.
NOTE CONF
It breaks the idea that everything's an object, that's for
sure.
NOTE CONF
If you're in a language where everything's an object, how
would you Where does this main object come from that
NOTE CONF
you're gonna start with?
So Scarlet's approach to this is something they call companion
NOTE CONF
objects.
The companion object says for every class you define magically,
NOTE CONF
you also define is a single object with that name,
and it's empty unless you put something in it.
NOTE CONF
So if you put something in it, those become like
the static methods, uh, in the in the normal R
NOTE CONF
language.
And maybe you can see why this might be a
NOTE CONF
better approach.
Because once you're doing static methods, you you've probably had
NOTE CONF
this compiler error.
It says you can't call a sta non static variable
NOTE CONF
from a static context.
And you gotta remember that static FOID main can only
NOTE CONF
call methods.
Uh, only call fields that are also static on the
NOTE CONF
same class, and you've got a mixture of statics and
non statics all in the one class.
NOTE CONF
The object takes that away because, you know, you've defined
a class and an object, and so anything that's happening
NOTE CONF
in the object has to be defined in the object
completely separately to what's being defined in the class.
NOTE CONF
So it's just a companion objects the right phrase for
it.
NOTE CONF
So did we get a companion object when we did
this?
NOTE CONF
Let's see.
Um, no.
NOTE CONF
Cool.
So I don't know why it's not there.
NOTE CONF
I'm expecting it to be there every time.
But I can do this if I use the object
NOTE CONF
keyword instead of the I think I need to do
that.
NOTE CONF
No, in case of the instead of the class ski.
Oh, there you go.
NOTE CONF
Oh, it's cos I'm in the interpreter that I can't
do this.
NOTE CONF
Um, so let's get an actual file up Patrol.
Q kills my, uh, sorry colon Q kills my interpreter.
NOTE CONF
Colon, Whatever does interpreter commands instead of scarlet commands?
That's also something they inherited from the functional world.
NOTE CONF
That's smart.
OK, um, in Scala, you don't.
NOTE CONF
Ah, I just won't find it, Will.
It never does.
NOTE CONF
No.
Um, in Scala, you don't have to make the file
NOTE CONF
name.
Match the package name and everything else.
NOTE CONF
Uh, you don't You can just put anything you want
in a scalar file, and it'll get run like a
NOTE CONF
script, so I'll just make this empty for now.
But this is how I would make a companion object.
NOTE CONF
Now, let's see if this can work.
So, Scala, like at Gala?
NOTE CONF
Oh, I complained about something.
The X isn't the Oh, yeah, I need that.
NOTE CONF
But it's complaining about something else.
They're probably gonna plan to get it again.
NOTE CONF
Diag!
That's a weird one.
NOTE CONF
Diagnostic listener Error.
Yeah, it looks like I've gone deep into problem space
NOTE CONF
here.
Ah, I've got a weird, broken arrow going on here.
NOTE CONF
I don't think I've installed enough of this car.
Yeah, OK, that's deep inside, Scala.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna have to chase that up separately.
Alright, so I can't run this to show you But,
NOTE CONF
um, this is on my image, so I better fix
it because the rest of you want to use it
NOTE CONF
as well.
But this is how you create static like things in
NOTE CONF
Skala, you make an entirely separate companion object that is
already an object.
NOTE CONF
So you don't have to make a new version of
it.
NOTE CONF
And it has a method defined on it.
So once I've done this, I should have been able
NOTE CONF
to do I mean, it won't run up for me,
but Oh, does this work?
NOTE CONF
Yeah, I meant load.
Oh, you go.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, but I'm just getting that error again to the
thing I say.
NOTE CONF
Do the thing.
Oh, there you go.
NOTE CONF
Alright, so it's just a warning.
I'm doing something wrong with the warning ways.
NOTE CONF
Alright, Uh, there's an example of me loading up the
scale of interpreter and then loading another scalar file.
NOTE CONF
Just the file I was interested in.
It gave me a warning.
NOTE CONF
I'd chase that up because there's something about scarlet have
forgotten, but it looks like I'm running a static method,
NOTE CONF
but I'm not.
I'm actually just calling up this special object that the
NOTE CONF
compiler created for me.
Just a single static, a single companion object to go
NOTE CONF
with the class and then that's all just floating around,
ready for me to use when I need to.
NOTE CONF
And there's nothing static.
So a main object is how you'll create a main
NOTE CONF
method in Scala instead of a static on a main
class.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, Scara also improves on inheritance.
Yes, traits.
NOTE CONF
They're talking about traits here.
Ok, uh, so that little short on the traits.
NOTE CONF
Alright, So what's the thing that comes up in every
other language?
NOTE CONF
Multiple inheritance, Every other language has its own way of
solving multiple inheritance.
NOTE CONF
C++ sets a bunch of precedence rules based on how
you defined it, which is actually I always like that
NOTE CONF
way Java says no.
You can only do multiple inheritance from interfaces.
NOTE CONF
Scala says We're gonna introduce.
We don't like interfaces.
NOTE CONF
We're gonna introduce a brand new thing called traits which
are halfway between interfaces and abstract classes and are more
NOTE CONF
powerful, and you're gonna use them when you want to
do multiple inheritance.
NOTE CONF
But by switching to traits, they also switch the language.
So they're not.
NOTE CONF
They're trying to get you away from the idea of
thinking about multiple inheritance.
NOTE CONF
And they're trying to make you think of a trait
not as another class you're inheriting from, but as a
NOTE CONF
set of methods you're incorporating.
Yeah, semantically.
NOTE CONF
That's a very small difference.
What is a class if it's not a set of
NOTE CONF
methods, but they use the word behaviour.
So you might define a square to be a subclass
NOTE CONF
of a rectangle and then introduce the printable behaviour and
then introduce the readable behaviour.
NOTE CONF
And then and those behaviours come in via traits.
And now the printable behaviour will give you a two
NOTE CONF
string method, and the readable behaviour will give you a
dot read method.
NOTE CONF
Um, but the key is to think of them as
not as identity.
NOTE CONF
Your identity still gets inherited through one chain, but the
behaviours that you can have the methods that you can
NOTE CONF
roll in come from other places, and then you can
see from there you sh you you'd like to be
NOTE CONF
able to roll in babes without having to define the
behaviour so traits can have function definitions in them.
NOTE CONF
They don't have to be completely abstract.
And then there's a few interesting rules about how to
NOTE CONF
resolve.
If the two traits have brought in the same function.
NOTE CONF
How do you resolve which one?
Well, now we go back to what C++ might do
NOTE CONF
and just have a set of, uh, precedence rules to
help you out.
NOTE CONF
OK, let's double check if there's anything else I missed.
We didn't get to do the Rangers yet, so let's
NOTE CONF
do them because I got sidetracked on the syntax.
So one place that cool syntax with the method call
NOTE CONF
shows up nicely is with Rangers.
A range is a way to get a list of
NOTE CONF
numbers.
So if you want to get the numbers 1 to
NOTE CONF
100 in Java, you make a four loop that goes,
I equals nought to I is 100.
NOTE CONF
And then you put I's into the array one by
one by one by one.
NOTE CONF
It's a hassle, uh, a smarter way to do it.
That many languages Support is something called Range, where it
NOTE CONF
might have some syntax to help you create a range.
OK, so nought until five gives me back a range
NOTE CONF
that's got 01234.
And that looks like special scara syntax.
NOTE CONF
But maybe you realise by now it's not special syntax
at all.
NOTE CONF
It's actually, uh, integer called zero, and then the until
method defined on it and then the five parameter being
NOTE CONF
passed in.
And that gives me my range.
NOTE CONF
But hopefully it also shows you the power of that
syntax.
NOTE CONF
Because when I do a four loop in Scala, I
will tend to do lets just get the syntax right.
NOTE CONF
I a four.
The syntax is Give me the variable name and variable
NOTE CONF
name is gonna get its values from a range.
It's only gonna be arranged.
NOTE CONF
It's gotta go over here on the right.
So something over here has to be arranged.
NOTE CONF
And then I will print line just the eye.
So that's gonna cash because I haven't told her what
NOTE CONF
the range is.
But I can construct a range with this syntax I
NOTE CONF
showed you before.
OK, 0125.
NOTE CONF
But I hope you can see that things are getting
a bit icky.
NOTE CONF
So this is I'm not doing this is all the
scarlet syntax.
NOTE CONF
I'm not using any of the sugar.
I'm just doing the scara.
NOTE CONF
So this is part of scarlet syntax.
This is part of scarlet syntax, the for loop, the
NOTE CONF
little arrow to say this value gets its values from
this range.
NOTE CONF
And so you'll think of that just like the Java
version.
NOTE CONF
But the Java version you gotta put in I and
you gotta put coal on and then the range.
NOTE CONF
But this might show you why the, um the syntax
sugar is such a win.
NOTE CONF
OK, syntactic sugar is getting rid of, uh, parentheses and
dots and things that are just in the way.
NOTE CONF
This is definitely easier to read than that.
Um, and a lot of people will start programming scalar
NOTE CONF
and not even realise that they're just using a method
up there.
NOTE CONF
They think they're using a special keyword, and then they
discover, actually, I can put anything in here, and so
NOTE CONF
I'm not restricted just until, um, And until we can
take a step.
NOTE CONF
So let me show you this one.
If I do not until 50.
NOTE CONF
Step 10, I get back to.
So until is more powerful than that.
NOTE CONF
But of course, this syntactic sugar is great for the
simple version.
NOTE CONF
But if I wanted to put the step in here,
the syntactic sugar is completely gonna fall apart.
NOTE CONF
And I have to introduce a new keyword, but the
Scalar programmer just goes, Oh, I've moved to a slightly
NOTE CONF
more complex situation.
I'm just gonna have to learn the slightly more complex
NOTE CONF
rule.
Fine.
NOTE CONF
So when I'm in simple land, I get to use
a simple one.
NOTE CONF
And when I'm in complex land, I get to use
the complex one and it's the same concept and I
NOTE CONF
didn't really have to learn anything new, whereas another language
would have to introduce an entire type of syntax and
NOTE CONF
a PAS rules so that I could say 50 step
10 especially Well, whichever one you're gonna use the language
NOTE CONF
chooses.
But in a language where this was a keyword, this
NOTE CONF
has to be a keyword, too.
In a language where this is sugar, I can just
NOTE CONF
expand on the method called I'm just using standard overloading.
And yes, I have lost a little bit here, right?
NOTE CONF
This is a little bit nicer to read the myth.
But in the grand scheme of giving people power without
NOTE CONF
overwhelming them with syntax, it's a good middle ground.
OK, any other questions?
NOTE CONF
Mhm the sugar.
What?
NOTE CONF
So that 50 comma 10.
How is that?
NOTE CONF
I'm not quite see how to step things.
Oh, it's not.
NOTE CONF
I made that up.
No, no, that doesn't do sugar.
NOTE CONF
That's what you'd have to do in a language like
python or something else.
NOTE CONF
Oh, I see what you're saying.
OK, All good.
NOTE CONF
All right, then.
I think we're done.
NOTE CONF
Thank you, everybody.
I just see him in three weeks.
NOTE CONF
1123.
Yes, I thank you for coming by.
NOTE CONF
I appreciate it.
Lovely people.
NOTE CONF
I would see it if you don't.
Yeah, in the last four.
NOTE CONF
Were you?
Uh, no, I need help.
NOTE CONF
I should carry these over if you get back.
But I just got a message.
NOTE CONF
Yes.
OK, so it's give me three shakes when I get
NOTE CONF
to the bathroom.
Thank you.
NOTE CONF
Just thank you.
Just
NOTE CONF